نحن نتحدث الآن عن الصحة
الشخصية من الداخل والخارج ، ما نأكله
وكيف نتحرك دون الحاجة إلى
التضحية بالأشياء الجيدة.
عادةً ما تكون لفائف الخبز أو المافن
منخفضة السعرات الحرارية إذا كان بإمكانك الحصول على قمح كامل
أو حبوب متعددة إضافية مقابل باك الخاص بك
بسبب تلك الألياف
التي هي مدرب الأداء جاكوب زيمر
الذي يريد منك التخلص من كل
ما قيل لك عن فقدان الوزن
من إخبارك  لتجنب كحول الخبز
وعدم تناول الطعام بالخارج ، انضم إلي
كلوي ميلوس الآن.
نظام غذائي اعتقدت أنه يجب
أن تكون جائعًا في نظام غذائي لقد جربت
كل شيء
منذ أن أنجبت طفلي ، لكن طريقته
تعمل حقًا ونعم يمكنك تناول وجبات سريعة
إذا كنت سأخرج لتناول وجبة
سريعة  مطعم لا يزال بإمكانك إنقاص الوزن ،
المفتاح هو حجم الجزء الذي يعتقد الناس أن
هناك أطعمة سحرية تمنعهم
من فقدان الوزن ولكن الحقيقة هي
أن كمية الأجزاء التي تتناولها هي
ما يجعل الناس يكتسبون أو يفقدون
الوزن ، لذا فإن شيئًا مثل مخفوق الكوخ
سأحصل على البرجر الذي يتم
تقسيمه فعليًا في شيك شاك ليكون أقل من 400
سعرة حرارية ، لكنني لن أحصل على
البطاطس المقلية التي تحتوي كل بطاطس فرنسية على 27
سعرة حرارية ، لذا فإن البطاطس المقلية المتوسطة هي
نفسها تقريبًا مثل اثنتين من البرغر ، فقط احصل
على البرجر إذا كنت  ذهبت إلى شيبوتل ، سأحصل
على شيء مثل أرز القرنبيط
وتجنب الأرز ، كما أنني
أتجنب الأفوكادو ، وأنا أعلم أن الأفوكادو صحي
ولكنه يحتوي على نسبة عالية من السعرات الحرارية ، وإذا كنت
تريد إنقاص الوزن ، فعلينا خفض
السعرات الحرارية في مكان ما ، اختر شيئًا ما  مثل
الدجاج سيكون أقل دهونًا إذا
كنت في شبوتل إذا ذهبت إلى
شيء مثل ماكدونالدز ، فإن الخيارات
أكثر صعوبة قليلاً ولكن
هناك دائمًا سلطة الدجاج أو
الدجاج الملفوف  من خلال اتباع هذه الخطوط
مرة أخرى تجنب البطاطس المقلية
وتجنب اهتزازها أو تجنب المشروبات الغازية ،
يمكنك الحصول على نظام غذائي كخيار
سوزان لدي أيضًا أسئلة عن جاكوب
حول كمية المياه التي تحتاجها ، تحدث
معي حول إعداد الوجبة وبالطبع
يمكن للكحول  أنت تشرب على نظام غذائي ،
استمع ، أفضل طريقة لعدم الغش في نظامك الغذائي
هي إخراج الوجبات السريعة من منزلك
حتى لو كان لديك أطفال ، يجب أن
يكون لديك بعض الأشياء التي قد تتناولها في
بعض الأحيان ، وتخلص من تلك التي تتناولها.
تعجبك حقًا أي من الأشياء التي
تجد نفسك تختارها
للتخلص منها ، فقط قم بإزالتها من
المنزل
عند طهي العشاء ،
استخدم جزءًا إضافيًا لتناول طعام الغداء في اليوم التالي ،
ربما تناولت عشاءًا لذيذًا
تستمتع بتناوله مرة أخرى في  غداء قطف
الكحول الذي لا يحتوي على الكثير من
الإضافات ، لذلك إذا كنت سأحصل على
تيكيلا بدلاً من مارغريتا تيكيلا ، فإن
التكيلا المستقيم هو خيار أفضل بكثير من
النبيذ ، فهو بيرة جيدة تمامًا إذا
كانت بيرة أخف.  إعادة ذاهب إلى  احصل على
سعرات حرارية أقل لأنواع البيرة الداكنة الخاصة بك ،
ستكون أكثر سعرات حرارية ، لذا
سألتزم بأشياء مثل الخمور بدون
خلاط وأتمسك بالنبيذ على
نظام غذائي للبيرة لا يتعلق بتناول 365
يومًا في السنة بشكل مثالي ، ربما يكون
أقرب قليلاً  مثل تناول الطعام بشكل مثالي 310 يومًا في
السنة ، انظر إلى ما يمكنك تقليله
من تجنب الأطعمة المقلية التي تحتوي على
الكثير من الصلصة ، وإذا كان بإمكانك
تناول الكحول أو الحلوى ، فليس لديك كلاهما
، فستتناول الحلوى
تخطي المقبلات  الكحول فقط احصل على
الحلوى إذا كنت ستشرب الكحول
تخطي الحلوى
سوزان أحب أن جاكوب يقول إنه
ليس عليك أن تكون مثاليًا
365 يومًا في السنة ، أعرف نفسي
أحيانًا تسقط من العربة وأنت مثل
حسنًا ، ما هي النقطة التي تعرفها كما
لو كان لدي زوجان من الأوريو أو شريحة بيتزا
إنه لا يحبها ، ليس عليك أن تكون
مثاليًا طوال الوقت وأنا أحب أنك
تعرف أن تكون لطيفًا مع نفسك كم من
الأوريو الذي قد يكون صعبًا  مثل
ما قاله ابقيه بعيدًا عن هو  حد ذاتها
ولكن الاعتدال هو مفتاح كلوي شكرا لك
شكرا لك